so in what some are calling the  copyright decision of the century  in google versus oracle the supreme  court has signed it with  google this is a case that involved  google copying some code related to  oracle's software in an api now a lot of  people are saying that  this means apis are not copyrightable  that is not actually true  the supreme court didn't reach that  decision instead it focused on the  more narrow question of whether google's  use of this api code was fair use and  the supreme court said  that in this particular case this was  considered fair use that  google was only using a small part of  the implementing code that was used for  other purposes  and went through all the other fair use  factors and found in google's favor  so we'll see what repercussions this has  and how this affects the  copyrightability of  software well you have to do a fair use  analysis anytime you take someone else's  code  we'll see and i'll see you in court